First officer is one of the most beloved and important characters in all of Star
Trek.
In my view,
Spock is not just important to star trek because of his position as first
officer,
but because of what he's mentality,
decision making,
process in personality,
offer his insight into the human condition.
Spach clearly favors strongly.
He's Vulcan haven't x is it as expected for Vulcanus to act?
He is very purely coldly logical.
He doesn't have much respect for things that are based on emotion,
tradition,
intuition,
or other imperfect mentalities.
Viewing them as vapid and whimsical.
The creators that have very good job with contrast and him with Dr. McCoy who
typically jumps to make decisions based on what is morally correct and Kirk,
who as captain must make decisions based on both arguments and at times on a
dime,
but also with his own intuitive feelings that come with being a captain,
which both Mr Spock and document coy may at times lack,
at least in the original TV shows and movies.
Jj Abrams Spock is,
well,
we don't have to focus on that version right now.
Spock's code of decision making based on a logical analysis of the components of
something you can go many ways for him.
There are many times throughout the show where Spock is to show off his brain
power and willpower in front of the capricious emotional humans
approvable.
You'd make a splendid computer and this just one
that is very kind of you captain
in high stakes circumstances where the crew is in danger.
Many of the crew members may suffer emotional outbursts which can impede their
abilities.
Spock,
on the other hand shows the value of being able to remain cool,
calm,
and collected in high stakes circumstances and be able to control your emotions
from getting in the way of what makes sense.
Raising my voice back there,
it doesn't mean I was scared
to have a human thing called an adrenaline sound,
most inconvenient,
considered having it removed.
Spock again being without what he considers emotional drawbacks at times arrived
to conclusions which the crew,
but more importantly,
the audience may disagree with it.
First being contrary to human nature.
Spock then demonstrates the usefulness of training yourself to use your brains
to overcome situations which might overwhelm you.
Otherwise.
His victories are allegories of our own tribes,
over our passions and motions and animalistic instincts,
which would potentially do us harm.
Get us out.
Once we are,
we're unification will become a fact of life.
I will not read this or any other statement.
If you do not,
you will die.
All of you will die.
Since it is logical to conclude that you will kill us in any event,
I choose not to cooperate.
I hate guns.
That clip in particular is one of my favorite from the whole show.
For whatever reason,
that kind of reasoning is lacking in fictional stories and even the real world.
However,
Spock is not always right and sometimes being logical,
it can get you into trouble.
In a world that is not logical.
Spock is chosen the Vulcan way of life,
but he is still half human and deep down has more emotions than the average book
and accordingly,
with as many successes come,
moments where Spock fails,
when facing situations in which is emotions are compromised or when the crew was
Minda decision based on arguments outside of empirical data such as intuitive
feeling these decisions with which Spock would have originally disagreed
turnout,
sometimes it'd be the correct decisions after all sparked doesn't show much
concern for the citizens made by Kirk Macquire Scotty because they feel
something is off.
But many episodes of the show demonstrate the value of this intuition as well.
This is also symbolic of events we face in our daily lives.
Sometimes we just don't have empirical data to make a decision,
especially a pressing major decisions.
So we have to gamble on subjectivity and intuitive feelings.
It's a gamble for sure,
but relying on statistics alone can get you killed out in space and Spock
equally owes his life was human counterparts.
As for emotion.
There was a clear reason that in many episodes Spock has to come face to face
with him.
His emotions.
Logic is in reality,
not an end in itself.
Logic is a tool to achieve a state of,
as Aristotle put it,
goodness or wellbeing,
which is arguably an emotional state,
being content,
healthy,
joyful,
successful,
satisfied,
et cetera.
We may view responding to incidents with emotional outbursts and called logic as
very different,
but the end goal is the same.
The feeling of goodness.
Logic is simply more complex tool to achieve generally higher levels of this
good for lack of a better term,
Spock represents the optimistic view towards mankind to star trek held.
He is cold,
orderly and computer like,
but deep down he has a heart and throughout the series he triumphs with his
logical abilities but struggles to overcome this emotional weakness in his
vulnerabilities.
Likewise,
humans who are emotional beings must not only learn the value of impartial
decision making mass to the utilization of logic,
but they also must gain control of their inherently absurd emotions and find a
balance between the two and not shut one or the other out to build an ideal
world and reach an ideal state of being.
Our emotions may not make sense to and it'd be archaic.
Tools are for survival dating back to our primitive days,
but they're there whether we like it or not and we have to mature them and
recognize them.
What the Spock consider the ultimate good then to what end does utilize this
logic?
Well,
Spock is very clearly utilitarian.
Utilitarians are essentially concerned with making decisions that will benefit
the majority of people.
Spock is selfless and ways decisions based on how they would affect the whole
universe and all its inhabitants.
In the wrath of Khan,
he states his famous phrase
logic clearly dictates that the needs of the many outweigh the needs of the few.
Spoiler alert here for the wrath of Khan.
Spock isn't just saying this side,
I would Spock says he means,
and he demonstrates this to the ultimate degree when he sacrifices himself for
the wellbeing of the ship after all of Star Trek.
Remember the original Spock's final advice to himself,
but to us as well.
Squad.
In this case,
the jury is shelf a favor,
put her side logic to what feels right.
So in essence,
Fox character has many purposes and displays many parts of the human condition
as star trek has always,
always attempted to do.
He is a utilitarian.
Advocating for decisions are the most useful to the most people is logical
abilities or portrayals of the benefits of being able to maintain discipline and
develop the power to make decisions,
especially emotionally uncomfortable decisions which will be the most beneficial
in the long run or even save your life on the other side.
However,
his faults show that logic is not always the answer,
especially not in a world belt somewhat illogically.
Empirical data is best for science,
but in a split second decision,
if you forgo your intuition in favor of it,
you could lose your head for more videos.
Like this and videos on many other subjects.
Be sure to check a fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching and of course,
live long and prosper.